bTW Fabian one asks I'm just curious
several authors I read have discussed
how hot it is to sometimes kill off
certain characters which clearly is not
an issue here you've certainly killed
plenty off in your career both in and
out of a Song of Ice and Fire
which character was the toughest to kill
off well I won't mention any character
names but the red wedding was the
hardest thing I ever wrote and those who
read the books know what I'm referring
to that chapter occurs about two-thirds
of the way through Storm of Swords but
it was actually the last thing I wrote
for that book when I reached that
chapter I couldn't write it I skipped
over it I wrote it although aftermath
and you know the other things I wrote
the other wedding it was someone else'
dies that one was easy and fun to write
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because you know everybody wants to see
that low [ __ ] die
actually I'm being glib I should I
should say yeah that was an easier and
easier chapter to write but even even at
the moment that that particular little
[ __ ] does die I tried to write it so
that you would feel a moment of empathy
for him in his in his dying and you know
bring home the point that you know this
too was a was a human being who was who
was scared and and terrified and and
then dead but but only after everything
else was finished did I go back and
force myself to write the actual Wed
reading chapter simply because it was so
so painful to write I invest a lot in
these characters and and particularly
the viewpoint characters I live inside
their skin so it's a little bit like
killing part of yourself or smothering
one of your children but you know some
sometimes it has to be done for the
service of the Almighty God of the story
and the story always comes first and
related to that do you ever find that it
would have been more expedient had you
not kill the character off later on no
I'm not really not really you know
sometimes my my readers write me and
they wish I hadn't killed a particular
character but there was a reason for all
all of the major the major character
deaths I mean a lot of minor characters
die too and sometimes I don't even
remember that they're dead you know I
you know I'm saying some nights watched
extradition leaves out and as Fred bill
and Sam on it and you know Elio of
westeros points out you actually
actually Kill Bill do books ago oh damn
alright I forgot about that
he died in the fens attack but
fortunately I have fans who have sharper
eyes than I will point out this stuff
but the major character this and have
all been planned and are all a part of
the story and and I don't I don't regret
him